bonjour à tous hier soir les sénateurs
ont entamé l'examen du projet de loi de
finances rectificative pour 2013 hier
soir a eu lieu la discussion générale
débutée par le ministre de l'économie
pierre moscovici
car moscovici qu'il a profité de cette
prise de parole pour défendre l'ensemble
de sa politique économique pourtant le
collectif budgétaire est plutôt un texte
d'ajustements techniques un texte
permettant de collecter les besoins de
chaque ministère d'évaluer les recettes
de chaque ministère comme tous les
textes budgétaires ce tag devrait être
sans surprise rejeté par le sénat
puisque les communistes a priori et ne
devrait pas vous été favorablement à ce
texte qu'il suffit que leur voix manque
pour que la majorité de gauche ne soit
pas suffisante pour voter un texte au
sénat tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle pour l'examen des articles
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale de finances
rectificatif pour 2013 dans la suite de
la discussion générale
de la parole est à monsieur françois
fortassin pour le groupe r d est ce pour
six minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en plus
rare à ce temps ci misent les grands
mots se garnit rapidement
comme chaque année nous examinons en fin
d'exercice un projet de loi de finances
rectificative qui permet de procéder aux
ajustements de crédits nécessaires pour
respecter les équilibres remonter dans
le cadre de la loi de finances initiale
ce collectif budgétaire également
l'occasion de réviser les prévisions
économiques du début de l'année
aussi avoir un seul collectif budgétaire
me paraît être sur le planeur ton look
si quelque chose de tout à fait
acceptable si le pouvoir nous réjouir de
la réduction du déficit public dans le
sol d'effectifs est en amélioration
par rapport à 2012 même si cette
amélioration est toutefois moins
importante que celle prévue par loi de
finances initiale ou par le programme de
stabilité présenté en avril dernier
le redressement des finances publiques
est en bonne voie et il faut pas
relâcher cet effort d'autant plus il
faut pas non plus en rajouter car les
ménages et des entreprises ainsi que les
collectivités locales
sont
dans une situation qui pourrait devenir
insupportable s'il y avait des
prélèvements supplémentaires
la croissance reprend très timidement
je ne donnerai pas de chiffres ils ont
été abondamment du nez hier soir
d'autant plus que nous pouvons ne pas
être d'accord les uns et les autres sur
ces chiffes il me semble que le
gouvernement en raison de rester très
prudent quant aux hypothèses de point de
croissance en effet si les insa l'insee
a fait état d'une croissance de 0,5 au
deuxième trimestre l art puis annoncer
une rechute au troisième trimestre
sommes-nous dans une phase de l'amorçage
de reprise économique ou aux prémices
nouvelle récession toute la question est
là pour ma part je suis plutôt optimiste
et veut faire confiance au gouvernement
j'espère véritablement que nous sommes
en train de sortir la spirale des ventes
dévastatrice la crise et du chômage
d'autant plus que très souvent entre une
économie qui bat de l aile et une
économie qui se porte bien il ya une
différence très minime qui s'appelle la
confiance et la confiance ne se décrète
pas mais c'est quelque chose de très
important qui nous faire partager à nos
concitoyennes
un autre je pense que c'est justement le
moment d'agir pour rendre cette reprise
possible en adoptant des dispositions
favorables à l'emploi la croissance le
retour à la croissance parce race par
celui de la confiance que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure aussi bien en ce qui
concerne les ménages que les entreprises
permettez moi cependant de vous faire
part de quelques inquiétudes en ce qui
concerne l' important manque à gagner en
recettes dont fait état le collectif
budgétaire il me semble que
l'explication monsieur le rapporteur
général selon laquelle les consommateurs
ont reporté leurs achats sur les
produits moins chers
étaient exactes mais elle n'est
peut-être pas totalement suffisante il y
a aussi une perte de recettes
importantes en matière de tva
il est possible que de ce côté là les
choses s'améliorent car il y a
incontestablement des réserves aussi
bien au niveau bancaire qu'au niveau des
particuliers et il faudra bien que cet
argent circule
pouvez vous monsieur le ministre nous
donner votre sentiment sur les écarts
importants entre les prévisions et les
recettes effectives j'en viens
maintenant aux ouvertures et annulations
de crédits prévus par ce collectif
concernant les annulations peut se
féliciter qu'elles soient couvertes à
90% par la réserve de précaution
quant aux ouvertures elles concernent
principalement les dépenses
exceptionnelles liées au budget de
l'union européenne les politiques de
l'emploi de solidarité mais aussi aux
opérations extérieures du ministère de
la défense des opex toutefois le budget
de la défense diminue significativement
et il y avait un problème de
compréhension
qui semble paradoxal
la mission recherche et enseignement
supérieur suivi également des
annulations massives en autorisations
d'engagement qui pose question quant à
la mission écologie elle voit la
totalité de sa réserve 470 millions
d'euros annulé en ce qui concerne les
autres articles du collectif je constate
qu'un nombre très important de
dispositions additionnelles ont été
adoptés en cours d'examen du texte à
l'assemblée nationale
le nombre d'articles est passée de 33 à
plus de 90 essentiellement du fait
d'événements gouvernementaux nous
regrettons cette démarche qui nuit à la
lisibilité de la politique poursuivie et
un examen parlementaire de ce budget
rectificatif dans de bonnes conditions
et puis je dirais que les amendements
théoriquement c'est fait pour améliorer
le texte si le texte comporte tellement
lentement c'est que le texte initial
n'était était loin d'être parfait pour
quand même je crois le signaler quelques
fois
sur la deuxième partie du projet de loi
donc il faut que ces faits ne se
reproduisent pas de façon systématique
faut-il rappeler que les modifications
des conséquences sur les fonds de
péréquation ddm t au et de la cvae a été
votée pour ainsi dire en catimini à
l'assemblée nationale alors que le sénat
ne pouvait plus se prononcer ces
modifications des critères de
répartition sans aucune simulation sont
aussi relativement inacceptable or nous
sommes très inquiets quant au sort que
le gouvernement réserve article 58 du
projet de loi des finances pour 2014 qui
met en place un nouveau dispositif de
péréquation ddm théaux dont le critère
de répartition sont renvoyées à un
décret qui fait semble-t-il l'objet de
tractations entre l'adf et le
gouvernement monsieur le ministre je
vous interpelle sur ce problème ddmt
haut auquel
l'immense majorité des élus comprennent
rien
il serait judicieux d'avoir quelque
chose de relativement simple et
compréhensible par tous ceux qui sont
intéressés
monsieur le ministre vous avez notre
part annoncé aux députés les
modifications relatives à la péréquation
deuxième lecture à l'assemblée ces
dispositions appartenant à la seconde
partie du budget le sénat l'examinera
malheureusement pas nous attendons des
mesures des engagements concrets de
votre porte de votre part qu'il soit
pris dans le cadre de ce projet de loi
de finances rectificative pour garantir
une péréquation
véritablement juste efficace et c'est
tout le sens même de la péréquation
sous réserve et parce que ce projet de
loi de finances rectificative doit
d'abord permettre retrouver la
croissance très attendu la majorité des
groupes du rdse lui apportera son
soutien d'autre part je voudrais aussi
signalé que sur le plan budgétaire
nous ne partageons pas les affres de
notre collègue de l'âpre
ça ne va pas tarder mon cher mon cher qu
moins chers collègues je vous je vous
propose de conclure de ne pas débattre
mais je ne débat pas je sais dit
simplement que c'est une sorte
pourfendeur des déficits mais qui est
simplement un plat mnésiques par rapport
à la période précédente
la situation de notre pays au fonds et
certains moins bonne que certains
optimistes vous monsieur monsieur
fortassin six doubles et si vous pouvez
vous acheminer à votre conclusion je
conclu monsieur le président mais
j'étais obligé de raccourcir m'ennuie
donc la situation de notre pays
n'est peut-être pas aussi bonne que le
clament certains optimistes mais elle
est certainement meilleur que
certains pourfendeurs le veulent bien
nous le faire croire merci beaucoup
merci mon cher collègue
la parole à monsieur francis delattre
pour le groupe ump pour 15 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
je vais plutôt l'intention d'être gentil
les mots collègues
m'incite finalement à dire les choses
cette loi de finances en réalité
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président l premier bilan chiffré de vos
18 premiers mois de responsabilité
l'absence de cap économique
l'application désordonnée d'un projet
présidentiel inadapté aux réalités et le
métrage fiscale que nous ont conduits
connu produisent
incontestablement un chômage massif qui
est en réalité le vrai marqueur de votre
gestion en un an pendant 18 mois en un
an
vous avez supprimé nous constatons que
132 1000 emplois marchands ont disparu
et les ménages les plus modestes dont
nous pour vous nous parlez souvent on
veut leur pouvoir d'achat baisser de 1
9% par famille dans ce projet de loi
notamment se gausse que l'impôt sur le
revenu est maintenu un rendement correct
en oubliant de préciser que c'est
surtout la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires de 9 millions de
salariés qui a largement contribué à ce
résultat avec 4,5 milliards de recettes
supplémentaires
à comparer aux 2 300 millions d'euros
que devrait rapporter un jour peut-être
l'impôt à 75% sur les salaires
supérieurs à 1 million d'euros
qui sait en réalité un slogan populiste
faut faire payer les riches en réalité
dévastateur en image et qu'il rapportera
fiscalement que des bribes
cette comparaison démontrer il eu ce que
dit monsieur julien notamment je crois
que tout le monde le connaît que des
saisies des filets ya bien longtemps que
le parti socialiste aujourd'hui aux
affaires n'est plus le représentant ni
des couches populaires ni du monde
d'autres avenues du monde du travail ce
dernier effectivement ce monde du
travail est bien éloigné dans ses
préoccupations quotidiennes de votre
forme du sociétal qui occupe l'essentiel
de vos congrès d'ailleurs le budget 2014
incarnera encore un peu plus cette d ans
en taxant 960 millions d'euros 13
millions de salariés accédant à une
complémentaire santé en intégrant cet
avantage dans leur assiette fiscale vous
croyez andré mes chers collègues que ça
fait beaucoup de riches en sus
affaiblissement du quotient familial qui
apportera à milhas et la fiscalisation
de 10 % de majoration sur les retraités
et enlevé trois enfants qui racontera de
gaulle 2 milliards d'euros et touchant 3
millions de foyers il use parfaitement
la réalité de savoir qui paye
ce sont les couches moyennes et les
couches populaires qui ont largement et
qui vont largement payé le choc fiscal
qui vous êtes à paris monsieur le
ministre à mi août après dix-huit mois
de gouvernance socialiste le climat est
anxiogène et les tensions croissent en
bretagne mais en réalité sur tout le
territoire la france est engluée dans la
crise 0 1% de croissance on sort à peine
de la récession c'est bien mais ce n'est
pas suffisant elle rejoint peu à peu les
pays du sud de l'europe et le
différentiel de croissance va
s'accentuer l'allemagne sera 1,7 au
royaume uni à 2,5 et nous serons donc
forcément la traîne le déficit des
comptes publics se rappelle réduit l'an
prochain 3 27% du pile alors que
l'allemagne est à l'équilibré notre pays
ne gagne rien en compétitivité et le
sait ici ce ne fut jusqu'à ce jour qu'un
renfort médiatique
et pendant ce temps-là remet notre
déficit du commerce extérieur va empirer
selon l' ocde de 2,2 du pib en 2013 à 2
14 en 2014
l'investissement des entreprises est en
panne le sioniste et la non
déductibilité fiscale des intérêts des
prêts faits justement pour investir et
une vraie calamité pour l'investissement
dans un pays où le crédit bancaire
finance 80 % des immobilisations et
faute d'investisseurs privés ou
professionnels fonds de pension et
autres alors il ya dans ce budget
quelques substantif mais en réalité on
est quand même très loin de ce qu'il
nous faudrait le taux de prélèvements
obligatoires
passé de 45 % en 2012 à 46 en 2013
continuera d'augmenter pour passer à 46
en 2014 vous êtes placé sur la deuxième
marche du podium des pays de l'oci les
yeux et vu les perspectives et les
prolongements plausible à votre
politique fiscale d'ici deux ans nous
devrions monter sur la plus haute sur le
land déclaré il ya quelques années au
dessus de 45 % le caractère
insupportable de l'un peut peut se poser
il semblerait que l'exercice du pouvoir
les fait changer d'avis la dépense
exécuté en 2013 sera supérieur de 2 4
milliards d'euros par rapport à la
dépense exécuté en 2012 les économies
doivent être calculés par rapport à ce
qui a été réalisé l'année précédente et
non par rapport à une tendance comme
cela est fait aujourd'hui
en réalité nous assistons à réalisme
arrondissement dans la hausse des
dépenses publiques en 2013 ou frisé la
médaille d'or de l' ocde et la cour des
comptes vient de vous préciser que
d'importantes sources d'économies
pouvaient être mobilisées sans perdre en
qualité service public moi tous on se
demande pourquoi vous n'engagez pas
cette politique en accord avec le
conseil de la cour des comptes il y
avait des économies réelles sur lesquels
nous pouvions nous baser les intérêts de
la dette qui a coûté 1 9 milliard de
moins que prévu et les pensions 1,2
milliard de moi ce sont des économies
immédiates et rapide et bien non c est
communauté absorber certaines dépenses
ont été exceptionnels comme les
prélèvements faveur de l'union
européenne mais pour faire face à toutes
vos dépenses supplémentaires vous
annulez des crédits sur la recherche le
transport l'armement à 6 440 millions
d'euros ont été annulés pour les
infrastructures de transport 100 110
millions pour rff 180 millions détriment
d'agents des financement des
infrastructures de transport
rappellons rappelons que cela permettra
de compenser certaines dépenses
exorbitantes relatives notamment à
l'aide médicale d'état quant à la map la
modernisation de l'action publique qui
remplace ifa qui essaient de remplacer
la rgpp à coire certes elle réellement
quelles économies ont été réalisées
depuis sa mise en place quels sont les
objectifs chiffrés y en at il
des doutes émergent quant à son
efficacité
y compris dans vos rangs et jean il faut
que la maaf fasse preuve de sa fécondité
pour le moment ce n'est pas le cas de
monsieur eckert il doit y avoir d
évaluation et de la concertation mais il
ne faut pas que ça prenne du temps nous
perdons du temps un comité international
sur la mappe doit se tenir le 18
décembre mais aucune relation de
politiques publiques avec des économies
substantielles
mais jusqu'à ce jour dévoilé tant que la
map sur un exercice un peu était récent
objectif précisions chiffrées nous ne
parviendrons pas à réaliser les
économies dont nous dont nous parlons
tous estimé gilles carez
merci votre ministère tente bien sûr de
réorienter la map afin de lui assigner
des objectifs d'économies plus tangible
mais je vous invite les cirques
collègues à lire le rapport du think
tank terra nova sur la réforme de l'état
très instructif c'est quand même 500 de
gauche il critique l'inaction du
gouvernement héros entre guillemets les
ministres ont at-il personnel peu ou pas
atterré impulsé dans l'oeil dans leur
champ des réformes ambitieuses de
l'action publique lors des réunions de
la map les sujets abordés sont mineurs
les politiques ministérielles évaluer
son de second plan tandis que les sujets
centraux sont laissés dans l'ombre les
seuls véritables économies sont ici d'un
coup de rabot sur le financement
l'apprentissage de la baisse de
plusieurs aides locales aux entreprises
et de la diminution des dotations
publiques aux chambres consulaires une
liste à la prévert distille de
mesurettes de mesures gadgets le rapport
se termine par plusieurs conseils que
vous devriez vous approprier monsieur le
ministre le calendrier des actions doit
être réaliste et la communication
gouvernementale claire les réformes
structurelles prendront du temps et la
maîtrise du déficit passera dans
l'intervalle par une diminution des
dépenses d'intervention il y a urgence à
travailler sur des réformes
structurelles mais vous avez pendant ce
temps-là ouvert les vannes dès votre
arrivée en arrêtant la baisse des
emplois publics en supprimant le
conseiller territorial en rajoutant même
strate dominé d'administration
s'agissant des recettes le rendement nos
impôts décroche par rapport à la
croissance du pib mais surtout le
rendement des impôts d on regarde la
forte hausse du taux de prélèvements
obligatoires vous aviez voté dans la loi
de finances initiale 30 milliards
d'impôts supplémentaires il manque
aujourd'hui 11 milliards pour régler
l'ensemble des cons de l'année 2013
comment l'expliquer monsieur cazeneuve a
rétorqué que cela était dû à des raisons
conjoncturelles
nous le compte nous ne comprenons pas je
pense que le comportement du
contribuable change et comme l'a
démontré pour bien connue celle de
monsieur la faire trop d'impôt tué
l'impôt malgré tout toutes les
délégations officielles nous en avons
une démonstration aujourd'hui 3 mai 3,8
milliards d'impôts sur les sociétés en
moins 5 6 milliards nos tv en moins et 3
1 milliards d'impôts sont revenus
manquent à l'appel la commission
européenne aux et d'hier monsieur le
ministre elle vous a donné un blanc
celle que vous encourager elle précise
quand même compte tenu des risques qui
pèsent sur les prévisions d'amélioration
du solde structurel en 2013 et 2014 et
de l'écart important attendu par rapport
à l'objectif de 2015 la france devrait
exécuter rigoureusement le budget 2014
et prendre un ensemble significatif de
mesures pour 2015 en plus de celles déjà
prévues afin de parvenir aux
améliorations du sol structurelles
recommandé par la commission en outre
tout recèle un pru devrait être affectée
à la réduction du déficit ce n'est pas
le cas enfin les autorités sont invités
à éclairer les autorités françaises sont
invitées à accélérer la mise en oeuvre
de la recommandation budgétaire et mise
dans le contexte du semestre européen
s'agissant des dépenses pour 2013
nous passons ne sera pas tant général de
375 9 milliards d'euros à 318 3
milliards il s'agit donc d'une
augmentation de 2,4 milliards d'euros
quand on regarde les dépenses publiques
de l'état des collectivités
territoriales de la sécurité sociale la
loi de programmation prévoyait 56 3% des
dépenses publiques consolidé pour 2013
le programme de stabilité prévoit 56 19
et nous atteignons finalement 57 en
exécution il ya donc que vous vouliez
pas un dérapage de 0,8 qui représente
plus aux 15 16 milliards d'euros
pour ce qui concerne les rentrées
d'impôt rapprochez vous des trésorerie
sur l'ensemble du territoire mes chers
collègues sur le ministre elle vous
conteront dans les mairies aussi les
histoires de ces milliers de français
qui ne peuvent pas faire face à
nombreuses augmentations d'impôts de
l'explosion du nombre de demandes de
recours gracieux ou d'échelonnement de
paiement vous avez fait le choix d'une
politique jusqu'à ce jour un peu à
rebours des stratégie d'allègement des
impôts poursuivi par les autres pays de
l'union européenne et on se rend compte
monsieur le ministre que ceux
aujourd'hui qui nous prennent des parts
de marché ce sont ceux qui ont fait les
efforts et en particulier l'espagne face
à la colère des français dont vous sur
heroes a réagi dans l'émotionnel il
paraît qu'il voulait même pas prévu en
proposant de mettre à plat la fiscalité
notre pays espérant ainsi calmer une
opinion de plus en plus rétives cela ne
ressort pas ne conte pas très bien au
contraire toutes les classes sont
ciblées elles le savent parfaitement et
c'est leur pouvoir d'achat qui risque
encore une fois d'être touchée avec bien
sûr tous les trémolos officielle sur la
justice ce collectif budgétaire qu'ils
auraient pu avoir un rôle de catalyseur
de la croissance la compétitivité est en
fait une ou un peu fourre-tout sans fil
conducteur le fléchage de lait par
devers investissements en actions dpe
est un outil est une mesure intéressante
mais le problème est qu'il faut toujours
rester vision avec vous car ce
dispositif finalement ne servira pas
qu'à financer les pme il financera aussi
le logement social l'économie sociale et
solidaire pourquoi pas mais dans quelles
proportions et est ce que le le ce ce
fléchage l'epargne n'est pas dont tout
le monde peut penser que les pme c'est
vraiment la priorité
c'est quand même une
une façon de faire qui nous paraît pas
être suffisamment réfléchi selon le
baromètre publié mardi par euler hermes
numéro un de l'assurance crédit en
france l'entreprise sur cinq envisage
une augmentation de ses investissements
2014 la situation encore plus tendue
pour les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire puisque ce chiffre passe
de une sur six selon cet organisme cette
prudence extrême sur les investissements
ça semble être le chaînon manquant d'une
vraie reprise en france pour 2014 il
rajoute leurs niveaux de marges n'a
jamais été aussi faible depuis 25 ans
bono dit monsieur milices simplification
de l'it d'accord ok mais s'agissant des
ja de l'amortissement fiscales de cinq
ans les investissements réalisés dans
les pme innovantes pourquoi les
soumettre à une obligation de
labellisation par la bpi a été on
rajoute à la complexité on rajoute et
est ce que la bpi est vraiment routier
est vraiment capable de le distinguer
les pme innovantes performantes
de même quelle est la cohérence qu'on
vous dit vouloir encourager
l'apprentissage et atteint les 500
milles apprentis que et que
parallèlement vous supprimez l'indemnité
compensatoire de formation pour les
entreprises de plus dit charly de 10
salariés est divisée de moitié celle qui
sera accordée à ces petites entreprises
ce ne sont pas les contrats d'avenir qui
leur permettront d'acquérir à nos jeunes
des compétences et un diplôme vous êtes
désormais monsieur le ministre largement
co responsable du désastre économique
dans lequel nous nous trouvons notre
croissance pour 2014 demeure en réalité
à prévisible vous dites qu'elle sera au
minimum de 0,9 contre 1 4% en allemagne
en europe avec un taux de chômage
allemand de 5 2% elle fait deux fois
mieux que nous où sont concrètement
aussi les projets de réindustralisation
de réindustralisation où elle plaît le
projet stratégique qui a été présentée
par monsieur gallois et a pratiquement
un an la reprise de la dette de le payer
cher le lyonnais par l'état pour un
montant de 4 48 milliards d'euros
remboursable au 31 décembre 2014
oh là là aussi une ingénierie financière
il restait deux emprunts ya plus
d'activité transformé dans une opération
budgétaire en une opération de
trésorerie ce projet de loi monsieur le
ministre monsieur chère collègue haïti
fictifs comporte une bonne mesure la
citation a réorienté notamment les
contrats d'assurance vers l'économie
réelle mais vous n'avez pu néanmoins
vous empêchez les associés quelques
taxes et prélèvements à quelques
complexité ainsi le résultat global
malheureusement va finalement ajoutée à
notre dette finale d'état et faute de
réformes structurelles courageuse
attendu par vaux prêteurs et aussi par
les français
mon cher collègue
la chute a été brutale monsieur le
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
bien monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs devraient
commencer par remercier tous les
orateurs de ce débat de qualité
départements ceux de la majorité le
rapporteur général françois marc ils
vont colin madame andré richard yung
monsieur fortassin pour leur soutien au
texte que nous soumettons aujourd'hui je
remercie également le sénateur place
aimé venir un peu différente je lui
ferai un sort un peu plus particulier
dans mes réponses évidemment et les
autres je les ai remerciés pour leur
soutien au texte que nous vous
soumettons aujourd'hui alors comme vous
l'avez remarqué monsieur le rapporteur
général une des premières vocation d'un
collectif budgétaire de fin d'année
c'est mettre en oeuvre les dispositions
qui permettent de tenir la norme de
dépense que nous nous sommes fixés il ya
cet égard le texte ne déroge pas à la
règle puisqu'il confirme notre
engagement au sérieux budgétaire et
jeudi au passage en effet monsieur place
et qui m'a pas ce site est très
correctement hier en tout cas je n'ai
pas souvenir des citations qu'il a pu
faire que le sérieux ce n'est pas
l'austérité que le sérieux c'est ce qui
permet un pays dû réduire son déficit et
puis progressivement d'aller vers le
désendettement
l'austérité c'est ce qui l'empêchent de
croître ses skis et coupe les moyens des
services publics et c'est ce qui prive
la cohésion sociale de l'élan nécessaire
donc je ce texte est sérieux il
documente précisément le strict respect
de la dépense de l'état
ils opèrent les mouvements de crédits
nécessaires pour financer les besoins
impératifs tout en veillant au respect
du total des dépenses autorisées par le
parlement mais vous l'avez souligné
comme les autres orateurs la majorité ce
texte ne se résume pas ne se résume pas
du tout même à ces ajustements
budgétaires il comporte aussi un salon
de mesures qui s'inscrivent dans la
politique de soutien à la croissance et
à la compétitivité l'économie à travers
la réforme de l'assurance vie leur
renforcement des garanties et sports et
les mesures de simplification que j'ai
présentée hier soir j'ai bien noté sur
rapporteur général votre volonté que les
services de l'administration fiscale
engage la réforme de révision des
valeurs locatives que vous avez
largement initiés et je veux vous
confirmer ici que ce sera le cas la
direction générale des finances
publiques est désormais prête à se
lancer dans l'expérimentation qui se
tiendra dans les deux années à venir je
me tourne maintenant vers le président
de la commission des finances en disant
ça peut être le surprendre peut-être pas
au fond que je peux souscrire à de
nombreux points de son analyse et et je
veux reconnaître monsieur marriner votre
effort très appréciable pour prendre de
la hauteur sur le texte qui vous est
présenté aujourd'hui même si évidemment
je ne peux que regretter le pessimisme
de votre présentation du bilan de
l'année 2013 nous en parlions une
pétaudière
votre démonstration était l'illustration
de ce qu'on peut faire dire aux chiffres
un peu tout et leur contraire il est
regardé avec lunettes que finalement on
choisit les vôtres était noir vous avez
posé la question de savoir ce que nous
retiendrons de l'année 2013 assurément
2013 et croyez que je ne suis pas versé
à la méthode coué ou à
l'autosatisfaction aura été une année
difficile pour les français dans un
contexte européen
encore très dégradé et plusieurs
orateurs de l'opposition
on répétait inlassablement oui mais vos
prévisions à 0 8 % etc je voudrais
franchement qu'on fasse là-dessus preuve
d'un peu de bonne foi oui nos prévisions
étaient à 0 8% mais qui ne se souvient
notamment de l'ancienne majorité de ce
qui était prévu par tous les instituts
de conjoncture et pas seulement pour la
france mais pour toute l'europe pour
cette année 2013 il s'est trouvé que la
crise de la zone euro et la france ne
s'est pas singularisé dans un sens ou
dans l'autre au contraire elle est
plutôt resté au dessus de la croissance
moyenne de la zone euro que la crise de
la zone euro s'est prolongé d'un an ce
qui a accru la dureté de la situation
pour les français et ce qui a accru
aussi la difficulté de la tâche pour les
finances publiques ne faites pas comme
s'il y avait eu dans cette année là une
exception française ou un problème
français ça n'est absolument pas le cas
nous devons être au contraire conscient
que ce qu'il faut redresser c'est la
situation de l'économie européenne toute
entière ce à quoi nous nous employons et
ce qui est en train d'arriver en 2013
puisque vous voyez cette zone euro
sortir de la récession et pays après
pays les nations de cette zone euro
retrouver la croissance à commencer par
l'espagne ce dont je me réjouis
absolument et c'est là c'était un rappel
qu'il fallait faire et c'est ce qui
explique tout simplement la raison pour
laquelle nous avons dû revoir nos
prévisions pour 2013 moi j'ai eu aussi
tendance tout en étant lucide sur ses
difficultés à retenir aussi des éléments
plus positifs de cette année 2013 et
vous comprendrez que j'adopte un prisme
légèrement différent du vôtre monsieur
le président sans pour autant mettre des
lunettes roses d'abord 2013 aura été une
année de réduction du déficit public
nominales comme structurelle et ceci
grâce en particulier au fait c'était
souligné pas tous les orateurs même pas
monsieur delattre suisse avec une autre
intention que j'ai bien comprise grâce
en partie au fait que les dépenses que
nous pilotons directement sa les
dépenses de l'état dépenses d'assurance
maladie
on était strictement tenu et tombe il
n'ya pas monsieur le président de
dérapage spectaculaire comme vous
l'indiquez des dépenses en 2013 au
contraire
je vous confirme l'intention l'ambition
du gouvernement de ralentir très
significativement le rythme d'évolution
des dépenses sur le quinquennat par
rapport il n'ayant pas d'amnésie là à la
tendance qui fut celle des cinq années
passées il ne s'agit pas de wishful
thinking les résultats sont déjà au
rendez-vous pour l'année 2013 s'agissant
la maîtrise des dépenses et s'agissant
de l'année 2014 vous le savez les
engagements pris sont bien qu'il y ait
une réduction des dépenses publiques de
4,15 milliards d'euros avec les normes
qui sont celles qui ont toujours été en
valeur et en vigueur pour cela en france
comme dans les pays de l'europe donc il
y à là les conséquences des décisions
qui figure dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2014 qui entrera en
vigueur après le vote par le parlement
et qui dit de manière très précise c'est
vrai que le sénat n'a pas eu je crois
l'occasion d'examiner comment les
économies en dépenses sont réalisés
deuxièmement l'année 2013 s'ils étaient
je vous le rappeler celle des premiers
signaux de reprise économique
évidemment en moyenne sur l'année la
croissance aura été faible très faible
alors été positive 0,1 point c'est notre
propre prévision 0,2 point c'est celle
de l'insee ou la banque de france celle
de la commission européenne de toute
façon c'est l'épaisseur du train mais
lorsqu'on observe les évolutions à fra
annuel c'est bien dès 2013 que nous
enregistrons à un retournement de
tendance qu'on peut tâter du printemps
et toutes les enquêtes de conjoncture
indique que la reprise est en marche
même si je les dis elle demeure encore
fragile encore insuffisante qu'elle a
besoin d'être confortés d'être musclé
d'être soutenu et nous sommes déjà sur
un rythme de croissance qui est de
l'ordre de 1 point par an
ce qui conforte les prévisions que nous
avons fait pour 2014 dont chacun est
sagement félicité reconnu qu'elle était
plausible réaliste solide il est vrai
que ne sont pas extravagante autour de
0,9 ou un point pour 2014 nous devons
nous voulons faire mieux et les
évolutions sur le front de l'emploi je
ne les rappelle pas je les ai présenté
hier sont également encourageantes pense
que nous devons tous nous réjouir quand
notre pays va mieux tous être satisfait
quand la croissance redémarre fut encore
trop lentement et tous également nous
féliciter que la situation de l'emploi
s'améliore et que les premiers chiffres
d' inversion de la courbe du chômage
pour les jeunes soient déjà intervenues
depuis six mois et que des signaux
soient donnés pour l'ensemble de la
situation de l'emploi je retiens comme
les orateurs de la majorité notamment
michel andré et chariots mieux jean
vincent placé que 2013 sera marqué une
amélioration notable de la gouvernance
des finances publiques nous avons décidé
de ne pas procéder un collectif
budgétaire en cours d'année
c'est que les parlementaires de
l'opposition c'était plus le cas encore
l'assemblée nationale ici au sénat nous
le demandait ardemment vous aimez les
collectifs et bien moi je suis satisfait
que nous n'en ayons eu qu'un pour cette
année qui soit à la fois marquée par les
ajustements de nature financière et
technique qui était nécessaire et par la
volonté de mettre en place de nouveaux
outils de financement de l'économie et
que nous n'ayons pas céder en quoi que
ce soit aux injonctions qui nous ont été
faites car là pour préciser la formule
des formes et de monsieur de la r en
réalité ce que j'ai toujours refusé
c'était d'ajouter l'austérité à nos
difficultés la rigueur c'est un mot
compliqué oui on essaie toujours d'être
rigoureux dans sa démarche
intellectuelle et ce n'est pas une
défaut que d'être rigoureux dans la
gestion des finances publiques en même
temps une connotation
passez sur la politique de rigueur qui
fait qu'on ait fait je préfère
l'appellation de sérieux nous avons
refusé cette injonction à faire basculer
en réalité notre économie dans la
récession et si nous avions procédé aux
plans d'ajustement on nous demandait au
printemps sur la droite de cet hémicycle
et sur la droite de l'ensemble des
hémicycles et bien nous aurions eu pour
le coup une dégradation de la croissance
que nous avons évité grâce à cette
politique justement calibrée est tenu
jusqu'au bout que nous vous présentons
aujourd'hui
nous avons souhaité un pilotage par le
solde par l'effort structurel qui permet
de laisser jouer dans une certaine
mesure ce qu'on appelle les
stabilisateurs automatiques en cas
d'évolution défavorable de la
conjoncture économique et je pense au
contraire de ce que disait le président
de mari nick que c'est un progrès
indiscutables de notre gouvernance
budgétaire auquel je vous sais tous très
attachés sur les bancs de la haute
assemblée voilà le bilan alternatif
concurrent au vôtre monsieur le
président que je fais de cette année je
voudrais également remercier le
président d'avoir reconnu l'utilité de
la création du produit euro croissance
est là il a rejoint d'après ce que j'ai
noté l'ensemble des orateurs voilà une
réforme qui est nécessaire pour une
réforme qui est consensuelle voilà une
réforme qui est positive une réforme qui
a vocation à être neutre sur les équipes
financier de l'état une réforme que je
ne conçois ni comme une réforme de
rendement ni comme une réforme coûteuse
les mesures incitatives dewet être
financées c'est l'objet de la taxe sur
les assureurs quand officier sur les
contrats d'assurance vie c'est tout
simplement une mesure qui permettra que
notre législation en matière dit sf les
droits de succession soit effective car
en l'absence de reconnaissance des
assiettes fiscales l'administration ne
peut pas taxer chacun conviendra de cela
enfin je vous confirme que nous avons
bien tenu compte de ce que l'échec des
précédents que vous avez cités est né ce
cas dsk nous on a appris il nous a ainsi
semblé préjudiciable de prévoir une
allocation d'actifs qu'il soit trop
complexes ou trop contraignant
s'agissant des sénateurs de l'opposition
je voudrais remercier ceux qui ont
reconnu comme monsieur de montesquiou
après le président la commission des
finances le bien fondé des mesures
incitatives favorable à la croissance
dans le plfr et j'ai noté monsieur
montesquiou votre intérêt pour la
démarche ouverte transpartisane qui est
la nôtre dans le débat qui s'ouvre sur
la remise à plat de la fiscalité je le
dis d'ailleurs au passage je crois qu'il
est très important que toutes les forces
politiques y participent j'ai vu qu'il
pouvait y avoir débat ici ou là au sein
de l'opposition sur le fait de savoir
s'il fallait participer ou non à cette
réflexion je pense que c'est une
réflexion de bonne foi dont j'ai rappelé
ici les objectifs hier plus de
simplicité plus de lisibilité plus de
stabilité plus de justice qui mérite que
le débat soit nourrie par chacun mais
j'aurais aussi revenir sur quelques
points des interventions des sénateurs
des bancs de droite sur la politique
fiscale je ne dis pas que des efforts
ont été demandés aux français en 2012 et
en 2013 comme les années précédentes
d'ailleurs pourquoi parce que c'était à
court terme la condition du redressement
des comptes et la sauvegarde de nos
systèmes sociaux je voudrais rappeler
encore une fois et sans esprit polémique
la situation dans laquelle nous avons
trouvé les finances publiques en mai
2012 nous étions dans l'obligation
obligations que vous aviez contracté
lorsque vous étiez à droite la majorité
de résoudre les déficits de réduire les
déficits structurels de 4 points entre
2010 et 2013 sans quoi nous aurions été
soumis à des procédures tout à fait
désagréable et il est vraisemblable que
notre crédit hu était atteint très
durement et bien quand je suis arrivé à
bercy ce que j'ai trouvé c'est un point
et demi de réduction il fallait faire
deux points et demi entre la mi 2012 et
la fin 2013 je sais que c'est difficile
et quand il m'arrive d'évoquer le bilan
de la majorité précédente c'est à ça que
je fais référence oui c'est pas fini
nous continuons de payer ça nous
continuons de faire le redressement qui
est nécessaire et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je crois qu'il faut vraiment je
le dis certains sénateurs d'opposition
être très modeste par rapport à ça car
ce que nous réparons c'est ce qui a été
c'est ou dégradées alors voilà ce que
nous faisons si les rentrées fiscales
sont inférieurs aux prévisions initiales
c'est d'abord en raison d'une croissance
plus faible qu'anticipé mais aussi
beaucoup en raison d'effets d'élasticité
qui s'explique par l'évolution
défavorable et conjoncturelle de
certaines assiettes taxable je suis tout
à fait comptable des propos que je tiens
en général je m'efforce d'être cohérent
mais je n'ai jamais pensé pour ma part
qu'il y avait une quelconque courbe de
laffer qui s'appliquait sur des choses
plus technique et dont il faut bien
prendre en compte les effets on estime
ses effets des associations 4 points de
pib en 2013 baysse concentrer sur quatre
impôts pour lesquels une telle réaction
est tout à fait classique l'iace les
cotisations sociales la tva et enfin les
dmt aux éléments qui je l'espère sont de
nature à vous rassurer sur l'évolution
de l'assiette fiscale dans notre pays en
2014 et j insiste car il ya un
changement très claire de cap en 2013
nous avons procédé à une réduction des
déficits un effort budgétaire qui
reposait aux deux tiers sur les
prélèvements obligatoires est au tiers
sur les économies de dépenses publiques
en 2014 nous renversons la
problématique nous renversons aussi le
pourcentage puisque 80 % de l'effort
budgétaire est fait à travers des
économies 20% à travers des prélèvements
et encore ces 20% inclut-il la lutte
contre la fraude et l'optimisation
fiscale dont nous savons tous ici
surtout les banques qu'elle est une
nécessité pour le pays nécessitait
financière nécessité éthique également
et que c'est une démarche qui tente à
s'imposer de plus en plus à l'échelle
internationale et à l'échelle européenne
et originale les prélèvements
obligatoires n'augmente que de 0 05
point de pib en 2014 je répète ici
l'engagement que nous avons pris avec
bernard cazeneuve cazeneuve qu'en 2015
l'intégralité de l'effort budgétaire
soit accomplie par des économies voilà
nous faisons nous avons hérité d'une
situation budgétaire très complexe nous
avons pris des initiatives sans
précédent pour la croissance et l'emploi
le crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité
l'emploi deux fois plus puissant en
terme de baisse du coût du travail deux
fois moins pesant sur le coût du travail
que ceux qu'on appelait la tva le pseudo
tva sociale la relance des
investissements d'avenir l'extension du
crédit d'impôt recherche et je veux dire
ici que la remise à plat de la fiscalité
n'est pas la remise en cause de ce qui a
été fait mais son prolongement avec les
deux caps qui nous servent de boussole
la compétitivité d'une part la justice
d'autre part par ailleurs je ne peux
laisser dire à personne et plusieurs
orateurs monsieur de montesquiou
monsieur delattre il est le seconde je
ne peux laisser dire à personne que la
france aurait des crashs décrocher je
vous prendre quelques chiffres tout à
fait objectif depuis mai 2012 qui montre
deux choses d'abord l'ampleur de la
crise dans la zone euro la stagnation de
la zone euro et aussi le fait que la
france tient tout à fait son rang depuis
le troisième trimestre 2012 la france a
connu une croissance très faible de 0,1
point mais la zone euro est à -0 1 point
l'italie à -0 5 point l'espagne à -0 3
point et notre voisin allemand et je me
réjouis de ces forces je sais aussi ce
que nous devons prendre de l'exemple
qu'ils représentent à certains égards en
matière de compétitivité je suis aussi
ce qu'il ne faut pas prendre en matière
de précarité dans le voisin allemand a
lui connu une crise de une croissance de
0,2 point donc ne arrêtons d'être sans
arrêt dans l'autoflagellation dans
l'auto dénigrement de notre pays je
comprends qu'il y ait des débats
politiques et je comprends qu'on
critique un gouvernement j'ai longtemps
moi même été parlementaire d'opposition
mais soyons conscients qu'il ya une
limite à ne pas franchir c'est celle qui
consiste par ce qu on veut critiquer le
gouvernement a critiqué son propre pays
j'ai été très frappée monsieur de lacq
par une de vos tournure linguistique
vous avez dit à plusieurs reprises vous
êtes vous êtes mai nous parlons de la
france nous sommes et ça cette façon
d'être inclusif je crois que c'est
nécessaire quand on veut avoir un débat
qui prend de la hauteur non il n'ya pas
le pays de gauche et le pays de droite
il y à la france et c'est celle-là que
nous ne devons pas abîmer c'est celle là
que nous devons soutenir c'est celle là
que nous devons à l'occasion sublimer et
voilà j'ai ça très profondément dans mes
tripes et je voudrais que le débat
public soit capable de garder oui cette
dimension de patriotisme qui nous est
chère à tous et éviter les clivages
inutiles je veux rassurer monsieur
foucault que je ne mets pas parmi les
orateurs l'opposition mais dont j'ai
compris qu'il n'était pas très favorable
à ce plfr
sur au moins un point à savoir que le
financement de l'économie et notamment
celui des pme et des eti est une
priorité du gouvernement vous évoquez le
lien entre les mesures de ce collectif
est le bilan de la bpi bpi france je
vous confirme que ces mesures forme d'un
tout comme l'investissement public ne
peut pas être la seule réponse il faut
aussi je dirais d'abord favoriser
l'investissement privé dans les pme
pourquoi me demandez-vous ne pas aller
vers un durcissement de la fiscalité de
l'assurance vie je vous rappelle que le
rapport berger lefebvre du nom de ses
auteurs karine berger de mythes lefebvre
avait reconnu la nécessité d'une pâte
déstabiliser l'assurance vie vous savez
que c'est un placement qui est très cher
aux français
qu'ils y attache énormément d'importance
qu'ils sont très sensibles à l'ensemble
des garanties qu'elles représentent et
le gouvernement a été conscient de ça
j'essaie d'imaginer ce qu était une
certaine réaction si nous avions la
touche est par trop se produit donc nous
avons partagé la préconisation des deux
rapporteurs
l'idée n'est pas de sueur fiscalisés
l'idée c'est de mieux utiliser
l'avantagé fiscal consenti afin que les
produits de l' épargne
considérable drainé en assurance vie
14,6 milliards d'euros ait davantage
vers ce qui nous rassemble ici tous
c'est à dire la volonté que les pme du
pays que les étés eti de ce pays
investisse davantage et dès lors
embauchent davantage je termine par
monsieur placé pour lui rappeler que non
mais non pas une politique d'austérité
que le sérieux n'est pas l'austérité que
nous finançons nos priorités pour
l'avenir que nous finançons aussi nos
politiques pour l'emploi et je veux
l'assurer que comme l'a dit d'ailleurs
fort bien à richard you nous sommes
conscientes du risque d'un scénario à la
japonaise c'est celui ci précisément que
nous voulons conjurer par le soutien à
la croissance et à la compétitivité nous
ne perdons pas non plus de vue
l'objectif de justice fiscale les
hausses d'impôts qu'il a évoqué son prix
est remis est prioritairement ciblés sur
les plus favorisés et nous avons aussi
pris de nombreuses mesures de soutien au
pouvoir d'achat j'entends bien ce qu'il
ne cesse de répéter en plaidant pour une
autre politique je pense moi que quand
on regarde la politique économique au
fond il y a trois scénarios il ya un
scénario qui est un scénario anti
économique qui consiste à penser que les
politiques pour la compétitivité sont
des politiques inutiles qu'on a qu'à
continuer à faire ce plus classiquement
d'ailleurs certains partis ont pu faire
est distribuée distribuer distribué y
compris quand on n'a pas d'argent on
connaît le résultat de ces politiques là
ce sont des politiques qui conduisent à
la fois à l'échec financier et alain
succès économique le deuxième voie c'est
une voix qui au fond consiste à dire
abstrait lyon nous faisons litière des
obligations européennes et menant une
politique pour le coup à la japonaise
mais comme celle que mène aujourd'hui le
gouvernement ab je ne la partage pas je
pense que nous avons fait le choix de
l'euro et je sais qu'une telle politique
nous mettrait en contradiction tellement
frontale avec nos partenaires européens
à commencer par l'allemagne avec
lesquels et avec laquelle nos économies
sont tellement interpénétrés
interdépendantes que là encore nous
irions à une perte de crédibilité
massive et donc la voie que je suis ce
gouvernement je déteste dire qu'il n'y a
qu'une seule politique possible je vais
trop autre communiqué par le passé mais
ya une seule stratégie possible à
l'intérieur de laquelle on peut je crois
si on veut être efficace choisir des
variantes différentes la seule voie
c'est de réformer l'économie c'est de la
rendre plus forte c'est de redresser le
tissu productif essaie de le faire en
redressant les finances publiques en
réduisant les déficits en le faisant
sans nuire à la croissance c'est cette
voie là elle est étroite que le
gouvernement emprunte dans une situation
difficile celle qu'on lui a légué je
pense que cette voie elle commence à
être comprise je sais quelle est la
bonne et je vois surtout qu'elle porte
des résultats quand la croissance
redémarre quand la situation de l'emploi
s'améliore quand la compétitivité de nos
entreprises et soutenu je me sais que
c'est long je sais que c'est difficile
je sais beaucoup de français encore
souffrent des difficultés de la crise je
sais qu'ils attendent plus et plus vite
je sais aussi que ce cap doit être tenu
et que c'est celui ci qui permettra à la
france de se redresser et c'est celui ci
qu'on trouve dans ce projet de loi de
finances rectificative après les autres
textes financiers que nous avons
présentées depuis le début de cette
législature
merci monsieur le ministre
la discussion générale est close nous
passons à la discussion des articles et
nous en arrivons à l'article liminaire
pas demande de prise de parole
qui est pour son adoption
qui est contre
il est adopté
article premier qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est adopté
article 1 bis qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est adopté
article 2 plus l'état à qui et pour
qui et contre
l'abstention il est adopté
je vais mettre aux voix l'ensemble de la
première partie du projet de loi de
finances rectificatif pour 2013 je
rappelle qu'en application de l'article
47 bis du règlement lorsque le sénat
n'adopte pas la première partie d'un
projet de loi de finances l'ensemble du
projet de loi est considéré comme
rejetée thil des demandes d'explications
de vote monsieur de l'est vous avez la
parole pour explication de vote
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues quelques
mots j'ai bien écouté ce que dit
monsieur le ministre en réponse il n'a
pas donné toutes les réponses aux
questions que j'avais posé hier soir
assez tard peut-être que dans la nuit ça
n'a pas été suffisant mais j'aurais aimé
quand même réinsisté puisque il a dit
que la voix effectivement été tracé la
voie de renforcer notre compétitivité et
celle de d'assainir nos finances
publiques moi je suis d'accord sur les
objectifs après comme il l'a dit il y a
des moyens d'y arriver et c'est
là-dessus sans doute que nous divergeons
simplement
il a dit également que on aurait on
était sur la voie
de la maîtrise de la dette et voir de
son infléchissement alors j'aimerais
bien savoir quand est ce qu'ils voient
cet infléchissement est ce qu'il ne voit
qu un infléchissement où est ce qu'ils
voient une réduction de la dette et à
quel moment celle ci va intervenir parce
que pour l'instant je ne la vois pas
venir et sur l'argent que nous n'avons
pas et que nous distribuerons j'ai parlé
hier de quelques cadeaux alors il ya des
petits cadeaux il ya des grands cadeaux
et les grands cadeaux c'est 2 milliards
pour la bretagne 3 milliards pour
marseille que c'est que certains rêvent
de voir changer de majorité mais
j'aimerais j'aimerais savoir où sont
inscrits c'est ou vont être inscrits ces
deux et trois milliards 5 milliards donc
où est ce qu'ils vont être prélevés ils
ne sont bien sûr pas dans le collectif
que nous examinons ici mais je ne les ai
pas vu non plus je le répète dans le
budget 2014 donc j'aimerais quand même
savoir si les annonces qui sont faites
sont des annonces qui sont vraiment acté
dans des documents budgétaires ou est-ce
que c'est simplement voilà des effets
d'annoncé pour essayer de calmer la
situation et essayer de favoriser un
certain nombre de vos amis ensuite sur
le fond
on nous demande de voter sur la première
partie de ce collectif budgétaire alors
nous avons voté en grande partie au
groupe u10 contre la première partie du
plf
2014 ce qui fait que d'ailleurs nous
n'avons pas pu examiner la deuxième
partie j'étais pour ma part favorable à
l'examen de cette deuxième partie donc
je n'avais pas pris part au vote comme
un certain nombre de mes collègues
je pense que il s'agit ici d'un
collectif budgétaire et pas d'une loi de
finances initiale et donc nous allons
collectivement nous abstenir pour
permettre la discussion de la deuxième
partie parce que on a le sentiment que
si ce n'était pas le cas nous
arrêterions nos débats ici et que nous
pourrions pas aller plus loin c'est pas
si je me trompe et j'ai cette impression
là je verrai tout à l'heure dans les
résultats des votes si c'est le cas mais
en tout cas nous souhaitons
nous souhaitons aller plus loin dans la
discussion et en même temps ce n'est pas
une façon pour nous de dire que nous
sommes insensibles
à la situation qui nous est présenté
notamment aux déficits qui nous est
présenté comme un déficit en hausse de
10 milliards par rapport à celui qui
avait été annoncé initialement
puisqu'on est à 72 milliards et que pour
2014 on nous présente un déficit à 70
milliards avec des investissements
d'avenir 12 milliards qui ne sont pas
compris dans ce déficit montfa qui en
fait vienne le gonfler donc
nous souhaitons nous souhaitons que le
gouvernement s'engage résolument dans la
baisse des déficits il avait annoncé il
ya quelques mois 47,6 milliards en 2014
dans la loi de programmation qui avaient
été transmises à bruxelles vous rendez
compte mes chers collègues 47,6
milliards et on nous a présenté un
budget 2014 à 70 +12 donc on en est loin
on en est loin et moi je souhaite qu'on
soit sur cette voie là et que on
infléchissent réellement à la fois bien
sûr le corps qu'on réduise sérieusement
les déficits et qu'on réfléchisse la
courbe de croissance de la dette très
rapidement donc notre abstention sort
aujourd'hui n'est pas une abstention de
soutien ni d'indifférence et est une
abstention constructive qui veut nous
permettre ici au sénat de débattre un
peu plus avant des documents budgétaires
et ne pas s'arrêter tout de suite la
première partie voilà je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue il n'y a pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
je vais mettre aux voix l'ensemble de la
première partie du projet de loi qui est
pour son adoption
qui est contre
abstention la première partie du projet
de loi est adopté je mets au voile
articles 3 et l'état béquilles et pour
compte abstention adopté l'article 4
plus l'état ces mêmes votes même votre
article 5 plus l'état des mêmes votes
même votre article 5 bis même vote même
votre article 6 même vote même vote
avant l'article 7 nous arrivons à la
discussion de deux amendements
identiques faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune et la parole à
monsieur delattre
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues c'est un amendement au
relativement mineurs font bien le groupe
mais qui intéresse une partie
de la population en ce sens qu'il est
une possibilité de diversification
alimentaire un certain nombre de
valeurs de boissons
issues
d'origines animales sont parfois mal
supporté et s'éteint c'est une façon
d'avoir
un produit de remplacement origines donc
d'origine totalement
végétales et notamment du soja et qui
pourrait être
une boisson susceptible donc d'entrer
dans une diversification alimentaire
intelligente voilà l'objet de cet
amendement et qui naturellement une
conséquence fiscale puisque on l'exclût
du périmètre de la contribution perçue
sur les boissons les préparations
liquides pour les boissons destinées à
la consommation humaine
bien mes chers collègues donc je suis
saisi de deux amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion la commune le
premier
le 93 rectifié
vient d'être présenté donc
qu'est la vie ah non madame qui présente
le second amendement 237 rectifiée bien
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement qui est cher à notre collègue
virginie klès vise à exonérer certaines
boissons à base de soja de la
contribution sur les boissons à sucres
ajoutés d'autres boissons alternative
aux produits laitiers en étant exonérées
il paraît justifié qu'il en serait de
même pour les produits du soja qui sont
le plus souvent utilisée comme
complément ou substituts des produits
laitiers le coût de la contribution pour
les consommateurs est certes réduit 7
centimes par litre mais elle un impact
financier majeur pour les producteurs
une telle exonération coût réduit pour
les finances publiques permettraient de
soutenir une production innovante merci
je vous remercie recoller quel est
l'avis de la commission sur un portage
monsieur le président l'avis de la
commission et ça c'est que nous
demandons la vie du gouvernement puisque
cette exclusion pose en réalité une
question de santé publique
plus qu une question strictement
budgétaires et nous souhaitions
connaître l'avis du gouvernement sur ce
point
monsieur le ministre quel est l'avis du
gouvernement
oui le gouvernement n'est pas favorable
à cette proposition qui visait à
exonérer les boissons à base de soja
gouvernement a déjà admis l'exonération
de certains produits en raison de leur
usage médical comme les produits de
nutrition entérale pour les personnes
malades ou de l'absence de produits de
substitution pour les laits infantiles
et votre mesure même si elle ne concerne
que les produits à base de soja ben
ouvre en réalité la voix l'exonération
de tous les produits qui poursuivent une
finalité nutritionnelle ce qu'on appelle
notamment les alicaments le gouvernement
ne souhaite pas entrer dans une telle
logique qui aboutirait à mites et
l'assiette de la taxe et à diminuer son
rendement est votre ce stade de surcroît
votre mesure introduit une
discrimination entre les boissons qui me
semble-t-il rond le principe d'égalité
de traitement et vous fait courir un
risque constitutionnel enfin votre
amendement réduire elle produit de cette
taxe ce qui est bien sûr difficilement
acceptable dans le contexte budgétaire
actuel dans ces conditions je demande
aux orateurs qui se sont exprimés de
bien vouloir retirer cet amendement à
défaut je serai contraint de demander le
rejet
bien
madame andrée souhaitait prendre la
parole oui monsieur le président est
soumis je suis sensible à vos arguments
effectivement si cela doit introduire
une difficulté complémentaires et donner
une extension qui n'est pas forcément le
voeu de son auteur principal jeu
souscrit à votre souhait de retrait
bien monsieur delattre vous
laisser prospérer
il ya donc je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement 93 rectifié qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas adopté
nous en venons à l'article 7 avec une
demande de parole de monsieur francis
delattre
le président mes chers collègues que
monsieur luis tu vois l'objectif global
général de l'article 7 c'est d'orienter
nous en sommes tous d'accord sur le
principe une partie de l'ehpad
l'assurance-vie en direction des pme et
outils qu'ils rencontrent tout le monde
le sait dans ce pays des difficultés de
financement de leurs investissements
souvent et cela l'objectif est
et générale nous sommes tout à fait
d'accord toutefois
la réforme n'est pas neutre pour
certains contre ans qui ne
respecteraient pas la transformation
contrats en unités de compte assujettie
aux contraintes d'investissement qui
sont prévues par l'article or ces
contrats font quand même peser un risque
sur le contrat
par exemple si un bénéficiaire prudent
et en matière on sait très bien que
c'est une épargne de prudence il s'agit
ici de son patrimoine ne souhaite pas
réorienter sur l'assurance vie vers un
horizon forcément plus risqués il sera
fiscalement sanctionner la frénésie
fiscale
les permanents dans beaucoup de nos
textes elle ne s'arrête pas là puisque
la faim fait naître à nouveau fait
générateur d'imposition aux prélèvements
sociaux lors de l'atteinte au terme pour
les nouveaux contrats et monsieur
rabotage général dans la discussion nous
aurait eu une commission des finances il
nous a dit que finalement c'était les
assureurs eux-mêmes qu'ils souhaitaient
contribuer à une taxe nouvelle qui
compensait je sais trop quel avantage
alors peut-être que le gouvernement peut
être que le rapporteur général et les
éléments plus important qui sera utile à
clarifier alors le basculement vers un
nouveau profil de contrat appellent la
conclusion d'un nouveau contrat avec
l'ensemble des frais de gestion qui lui
sont aussi afférents alors non content
de toujours plus imposer des
particuliers durant leur vie ont sur
fiscalise ainsi les transmissions de
patrimoine qui tombe et qui tombent sur
des contribuables à un monde souvent
paraît évident leur existence
alors pour toutes ces raisons nous
souhaiterions avoir à la fois des
dispositions du rapporteur général sur
le positionnement des astuces et une
explication du ministre pour éviter que
ce ne soit en réalité un blocage
bien je suis saisi d'un amendement
64 qui est présentée par monsieur
foucault
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre
défend de
63 et 64 si vous voulez bien
puisque nous avons déjà eu l'occasion
lors de la discussion générale
de dire ce que nous pensions bien sûr de
cette réforme de l'assurance vie telles
que décrites dans cet article 7 et
préconise préconisée par le rapport qui
a rappelé tout à l'heure où monsieur le
ministre de nos collègues députés karine
berger et dominique lefebvre bien sûr
les enjeux sont connus il s'agit de
déplacer une partie de l'encours actuel
de la science vie c est environ 1450
milliards d'euros en hausse d'à coeur de
89 milliards d'euros depuis le début de
l'année et ceci du marché obligataire où
elle est en général investit vers le
segment des marchés financiers bien sûr
constitué par les actions il s'agit
selon le rapport précité de faire bouger
vers les nouveaux contrats case 1 25
milliard d'euros par an pour atteindre
100 milliards au terme du quinquennat
somme destinée au financement de nos
entreprises et notamment renforcement
bien sûr de leurs fonds propres tout
cela vise manière essentielle et
principal les plus gros détenteurs de
contrats en cours ce dont on peut penser
que le régime fiscal de l'assurance vie
participe pour eux d'un formidable outil
d'optimisation fiscale au demeurant
regrettons que le rapport n'ait fait
état des éléments
fournis par la cour des comptes comme
par le rapport bergier de fèves sur la
réalité de la concentration de
l'assurance vie au sein des ménages les
plus aisés la très grande majorité des
détenteurs de contrats d'assurance vie
et je lui ai rappelé hier soir dans
l'intervention général dans les
discussions qui ne sont aucunement
concernés par nos deux amendements 63 et
64 dispose en effet de moins de
cinquante mille euros de valeur
capitalisée
50% des ménages par contre détiennent 6
5% de l'encours total de l'assurance vie
et 90 % ne dispose que de 35,2 consent
de cet encours nous avons donc en
moyenne moins de trente cinq mille euros
d'assurance vie capitaliser pour 9
détenteurs sur dix alors la situation du
dernier décide de population est
totalement différente et l'assurance vie
et même dans sa détention encore plus
nettement concentré que les autres
formes de patrimoine financier matériel
oui mobilier les 10% de ménages les plus
aisés disposent en effet de 48% du
patrimoine total des ménages mais de
près de 65 % de l'encours d'assurance
vie je crois qu'ils veulent et que ça
soit il dit la source de financement de
la dette publique constitue l'assurance
vie devenue donc un objet d'optimisation
fiscale pour les plus fortunés là encore
pas ou peu de taxation titre de l' isf
déversement capitaliser effectué avant
l'âge de 70 ans étant je le rappelle
exonéré peu de droits de mutation alors
le minimum une imposition optionnel à
taux privilégiés et au dénouement du
contrat au titre de l'impôt sur le
revenu je dois dire que tout cela coûte
et coûte relativement cher aux finances
publiques
et c'est en quelque sorte ce que nous
voulons corriger pour partie avec ces
deux amendements portant d'une part sur
le retour un abattement plus faibles par
part de succession et d'autre part un
moindre abattement proportionnelle ce
serait de notre avis une bonne manière
de cesser de faire de l'assurance vie
cet outil d'optimisation fiscale pour le
moins coûteux que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui merci je vous remercie
chacun alors quel est l'avis de la
commission sur ces deux amendements
derrière du jeune premier tous les coms
sur le président l'avis de la commission
est le suivant c'est que sur le 64 sont
défavorable à cet amendement car il
pénaliserait proportionnellement plus
les petits contrats que les gros et
nuirait ainsi gravement me semble-t-il à
la progressivité de la taxation des
capitaux transmis par assurance vie donc
avis défavorable et s'agissant du 63
défavorable également car le seuil a
déjà été abaissée de 900 2008 138 euros
à 700000 euros par nos collègues députés
ceci afin de neutraliser l'effet
d'aubaine coraci non représentés
l'abattement 20% pour certains contrats
importants dès lors je considère que le
défaut a été corrigé
et
tout d'abord en supplémentaire du seuil
irait à l'encontre des objectifs de la
réforme proposée qui n'est pas
d'alourdir la fiscalité sur les capitaux
transmis en cas de décès mais bien
d'assister à la transformation des
contrats actuels en contrats vie
générations et ceci afin de faciliter
l'orientation de cette épargne vers les
pme et dès lors tout abaissement
supplémentaire n'irait pas dans le sens
souhaité voilà avis défavorable
également pour celui là c'est le
ministre
donc même avis pour monsieur lui dise
donc je mets oui pour explication de
vote monsieur foucault
président de seconde je voudrais que
monsieur le rapporteur général me fasse
la démonstration s'il le peut pour
m'expliquer que les petits
possesseurs d'assurance-vie paieront
plus cher et peut-être pourrait-il
rappeler combien le budget de l'état va
perdre je crois que nous avions fait une
estimation entre 1,7 et 5,1 milliards
dont
monsieur rapporteur général oui la
question posée est tout à fait légitime
et je j'apporte effectivement à cette
question un élément complémentaire sur
la vie que j'ai donné en prenant un
petit exemple chiffré c'est que la part
taxable d'un bénéficiaire qui reçoit un
million d'euros
augmenterait d'environ 10% la part
taxable
alors que la part taxable de celui qui
reçoit deux cent mille euros serait plus
que triplé ce qui démontre très
clairement l'influencent
sensiblement plus importante pour un
petit contrat le bénéficiaire qui
reçoit un capital se situe aujourd'hui
juste au niveau du seuil d'exonération
serait désormais imposé sur 100 2500
euros soit un prélèvement passant de 0 à
plus de 20000 euros donc on sent bien
que cet amendement nuirait gravement à
la progressivité et c'est la raison pour
laquelle et il m'a semblé qu'il était
souhaitable de ne pas l'accepter pour
serait cette question de principe la
progressivité
voici quelques éléments additionnels
mais je ne sais pas si ça suffit à
convaincre notre collecte les retire le
moment
il n'y a pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote je n'en vois pas
donc je vais mettre au voir d'abord
l'amendement 64 qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 63 même vote
non explications de vote de madame
office oui on a bien entendu la réaction
du rapporteur général en réponse à nos
questionnements de thierry foucaud mais
je voudrais quand même rappeler que 90%
des 17 millions de souscripteurs le
montant épargné cumulée est inférieur à
50 mille euros
je crois qu'il faut il faut qu'on soit
clair donc en tournée sur 200 milles
c'est pas les 90%
bien
jeu mais se voit donc cet amendement 63
qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté j'en
viens à l'amendement 115 qui est
présentée par monsieur delattre
il est défendue non aller allons-y 100
cases mais en 15 maintenant bon le
gouvernement sujet à l'orientation des
détenteurs de patrimoines importants
vers des placements risqués grâce à la
vente moins de 20% c'était le placement
alors ce texte prévoit que pour des
secteurs de l'économie identifiés comme
prioritaires là dessus nous serons nous
sommes assez d'accord ce que le prince
lequel nous ne sommes pas d'accord c'est
qu'on pense qu'il faut privilégier
absolument les pme et des nti et ne pas
s'écarter vers l'économie sociale et
solidaire parce que en réalité si c'est
pour des financements plus ou moins à
déterminer ça nous paraît atténuer la
pertinence du dispositif alors voilà l
objet de deux sets à un amendement
monsieur le président je vous remercie
monsieur de d'un train
quel est l'avis de la commission
l'avis de la commission est simple c'est
que nous sommes défavorables à
l'exclusion du logement
la production de logements et bien un
secteur prioritaire de l'économie donc à
ce titre on voit pas très bien pourquoi
faudrait exclure
le logement social ou intermédiaire
d'économie sociale et solidaire du quota
d'investissement
dont un avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre
mon avis est également défavorable
simplement rappeler nos sénateurs
delattre que l'économie sociale et
solidaire est une vraie priorité du
gouvernement et que de surcroît c'est
une vraie économie ne faisons pas comme
si c'était une économie à part ou une
économie de second rang c'est une
priorité gouvernementale et c'est un
secteur économique est tout à fait
décisif dans l'économie du pays donc je
ne comprends pas discrimination et
j'ajoute cette remarque celle du
rapporteur général que je partage son
logement intermédiaire
bien monsieur le président à marigny
pour explication de votre explication de
vote en effet monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la question est de savoir monsieur le
ministre si l'on conçoit ici un produit
financier ou un mode de fléchage de
l'epargne en d'autres termes une sorte
de nouvelles niches fiscales
or nous sommes bien dans le domaine de
l'assurance vie il s'agit de capitaux a
placé qui attendent un certain rendement
l'assurance vie on peut le rappeler est
le produit financier préférée en france
et je crains qu'avec le caractère très
composite
qui serait donnée
aux actifs
de ce produit ainsi
proposés ou recalibrées et bien on ne
perturbe les anticipations et on ne
nuise au succès
du produit lui même alors j'y reviendrai
tout à leur compte tenu des mesures
fiscales qui à mon avis contrarie
également le succès l'émergence de vos
contrats euros en croissance mais je
m'associe bien volontiers à l'initiative
de mon collègue delattre en considérant
que nouvelle fois le gouvernement veut
faire beaucoup de choses avec un seul
geste ici avec un seul produit financier
et qu'il en résulte des contradictions
qui nuiront à la crédibilité du 10
produits financiers
je vous remercie sur le président n'y a
pas d'autres explications de vote je
mets donc aux voix cet amendement 115
qui et pour
qui est contraint
il s'abstient
n'est pas adopté
nous en venons à la l'amendement numéro
2 présenté par monsieur marc au nom de
la commission des finances
c'est un nom de coordination sur le
président bien
rédactionnelle bien donc je me vois cet
amendement de coordination qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté
je mets donc on voir l'article 7 ainsi
amendée
qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient l'article 7
est adoptée
après l'article 7 je suis saisi de deux
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune et 113 il est
présenté le premier par madame beaufils
l'amendement 66 oui je vous présente
très monsieur le président monsieur mini
ce cher collègue les deux amendements
ensemble la dépense fiscale liées à
l'imposition sur options et ato
libératoire privilégié des sommes
capitaliser sur les contrats d'assurance
vie constitue une charge budgétaire
assez signifie que